we don't even have to read any of the
comments i know we pulled some but it's
like it's fine
i just think that's the funniest part is
i know whoever's mad is really young
because
like what you said right there is
everyone passed 24.
are you seeing you seen the new batman
yet no i just i've been working
i thought it was kind of mid that's cool
yeah so i my my mom is like a like a
growth in her calf so i just been
thinking about how to how maybe i could
work from home for the rest of the year
you're like
okay but how about this though think
back
to when you first saw the dark knight
yeah
oh yeah i thought it was the greatest
movie that's what i'm saying if somebody
back then told you no right after you
saw it that it was mid that is actually
like direct like
yeah
yeah yeah
um
we should blow up your whole family's
house we should probably kill themselves
yeah we should kill your whole family
because you said that right now yeah no
i i distinctly remember loving it
and then like i think it was like my
friend's older brothers or something
like his older brother and his friends
were like yeah it was just whatever yeah
they're like it wasn't that good no
they're like you know i don't like nolan
i was like
i'm sorry
does not compute um
yeah then i then i pulled like the joker
card on the string out of my own jacket
i was like um
what did you just say
dude
i said i don't like nolan you want to
know how i got these scarves yeah
god damn i don't even have a funny
[ __ ]
i cut open my mouth so i could suck
nolan's gigantic penis
so i could suck his dick and balls at
the same time
the best director on earth deserves
pleasure
and then yeah and then his older
brothers and his friends are like dude
we just said the movie's mid like
i sucked his whole [ __ ]
and balls
[Laughter]
what is wrong with your
brother's friend what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this kid dude
i sucked he's not mid
it's all about the mid with you guys
[Laughter]
look at me
look at me
look at me
i put his whole [ __ ]
and balls
in my mouth
[Laughter]
after i saw the film
so let me tell you
what happens next
you watch the movie
and you like it
or i blow this whole place up
[Laughter]
now that
is cringe
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
i can't
i can't believe someone just like i said
the batman was mid and they drove their
ford f-150 into a tree like that's how
[ __ ] dead
some people were
it's okay guys we ruined their
wednesdays oh man
yeah yeah
uh we heard this and they're like well
saturdays are definitely not back dude
i'll be throwing up all day now
you